hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be giving you
the top seven things that you should
avoid
doing to your house if you're looking to
increase the value
to sell the property now these seven
things are things that people do to the
house
to try and push the value up they spend
money on a renovation to try and
increase the value
but in fact it actually decreases the
value
no god how disappointing would that be
imagine if you
did a renovation on a house or you spent
money on your property and it actually
made the
property shrink in value it would be
dreadfully painfully annoying which is
why i'm gonna list the seven things
in this video to avoid you losing money
however before i go through those seven
things please do me a massive massive
favor and
smash the like button i want to see the
blue thumb
pointing up that really helps me out and
i'm gonna start with number seven which
is the least
detrimental and then i'm gonna end up
going right through to number one and if
you do number one
oh my goodness you really need to stick
around to the end because they're gonna
get worse and worse and worse as we go
through them so
number seven is to add a
water feature or a swimming pool to your
garden now you might think if you add a
nice water feature a
pond or even a swimming pool to swim in
you might think that's going to push the
value up
but it actually costs a lot of money and
in many cases it will bring the value of
your house
down now the reason it brings the value
of the house down
is because people don't want to have to
maintain it and if let's face it if you
don't like swimming
if you don't want a swimming pool
outside in your garden it doesn't
add any value but you're gonna have to
maintain it you're gonna have to clean
it so it just becomes a
pain also if you've got small kids you
might fear the kids falling in it so
there's many reasons as to why it will
put some buyers off
and it has been proven in surveys and
statistics
that this can actually have a negative
impact on the valuation of your house so
that's number seven we're gonna get a
little bit worse and a little bit worse
number six is a garage conversion now
garage conversions can be quite
expensive
and if you're living in a property you
might think who needs a garage
conversion it's a waste of space maybe
you don't even have a car
and you turn it into a games room or an
extra sitting room and you think because
you've got an extra nice room
and you've insulated it and you've spent
money on it that's going to increase the
value of the house
wrong that's actually most likely going
to push the value
down on your property and the reason is
is because a lot of people are looking
to buy
a house they've got a checklist and
they're like right and on their
checklist
often is a garage so if you get rid
of one of the things that many people
are looking for you're gonna
decrease the chances of selling your
property quickly and
probably push down the value of the
property which again would be really
annoying because it costs a lot of money
to do that kind of renovation so just
spend money
and then to not make any back and
actually push the vote down terribly
terribly annoying
number five and these are getting worse
and worse is
wallpaper wallpaper is a very damaging
thing you can do to a house if you've
got a property and it's currently
painted
maybe you don't like the paint please
don't put wallpaper on it
i would never do this and probably most
people wouldn't but the problem with
wallpaper
is number one it kind of looks a little
bit old-fashioned and often a bit tacky
but that's not the main problem
the main problem is that wallpaper is
often used as a
cover up thing so when people see
there's a wallpapered room
in their minds they think underneath the
wallpaper there's probably
broken plaster it's going to need
replastering there's going to be cracks
so they when they're looking around the
property will start
calculating that into the cost of their
refurb and it might be that there's no
cracks you just happened to like
wallpaper and you invested money and
invested time wallpapering the room and
actually
brought the value of the house
considerably down don't do it folks
number four is turning your property
into an
open plan property now what that means
is let's say that at the moment you've
got two
reception rooms you've got a lounge and
a dining room and they're medium-sized
and you might think you know what
let's knock down the stood wall and open
it all up and have this a nice
spacious open plan property now you
might personally like that so you might
invest the time and money to make it
open plan
but many people don't like open plan and
it's not that they don't like open plan
it's that you're turning two rooms into
one room so
that's a problem because a lot of people
like extra rooms maybe they've got kids
and i think that could be the play room
that could be the adult room
suddenly you've turned it into this nice
open plan area
but now the house isn't suitable for
many families
and then what you've done you've brought
down the value of the house
number three these are getting worse and
worse by the way if you're enjoying the
video please again don't forget to smash
the like button
drop your comments as well below let me
know what you thinking of the video and
don't forget to subscribe
number three this one's terrible
honestly these are getting really bad
now i've been an
estate agent i used to be an estate
agent i've been in property as well as
an investor for over a decade
and whenever i see this i'm always like
why why would you do this and that's
when people turn
two bedrooms into one bedroom they merge
bedrooms
this is absolutely devastating to the
value of your house
another thing that's similar which is
also just ludicrous
is when people turn a small bedroom
into a bathroom it's just crazy and then
you end up with this ugly enormous
oversized
bathroom and you've gone from
three-bedroomed house into a two-bedroom
house
and suddenly that's going to bring the
value right down because a lot of people
want a third bedroom even if the
bedroom's small don't just think oh well
let's just turn into a bathroom well
let's just
knock down the wall and make the second
room a slightly bigger second room that
is
ridiculous thing to do if you're
planning on selling the property and it
is
gonna bring the value of the house down
number two we're getting bad now now i
don't know why this one is so bad
because these aren't just my opinion
these are things that statistically do
bring the value down
according to surveys and estate agents
but this one's really bad
and when i told my wife that she was
like i actually quite like this but
many people don't and that is artificial
grass
in the garden people hate artificial
grass now they might like it if they're
coming around your house as a visitor
but people for whatever reason do not
want to buy houses
where the garden is artificial grass
maybe they just freak out and think
there'll never be any grass or i don't
know what it is but
do not put artificial grass like astro
turf
in your garden it's gonna cost you money
but it's gonna bring the value right
down and it's gonna put
off buyers here we go now folks number
one
now this one i i've never come across
anybody do this deliberately i really
can't even quite believe anyone's done
this but apparently
this has happened and that is people
have put
japanese knotweed in their garden
as a garden plant i mean i'm really
still
not convinced that this has ever
actually happened for real
unless we're going to go back to
victorian times in the 19th century
when they brought japanese knotweed in
from japan as a plant and no one knew
how
how terrible it was but japanese
knotweed is a plant
that grows through concrete it will ruin
the structure of buildings
it is so unwanted that even if you take
it to a junkyard or a skip they will
refuse to have it it is illegal
to not treat it you can be fined up to 5
000 pounds and if you put japanese
knotweed in someone's garden as a prank
don't do that because you can even go to
prison that's how bad it is
so i'm sure you kind of wouldn't do this
anyway and i'm sure you weren't planning
on
putting japanese not within your garden
but if your house does have japanese
knotweed it can bring the value down so
badly
that the property is unmortgageable and
if a lender goes out to value the house
they can even value your property at
zero say what so you do
not want japanese knotweed and that's
why i saved it until the absolute number
one
devastating thing that you can do to
your house to bring the value down
folks thank you so much for watching the
video i hope you found it useful
again drop your comments in subscribe
smash the like button if you want to
learn more about property and you want
to get top
property investing tips you might enjoy
this video right here
if you want to see some of my students
that have succeeded in property as a
result of my training
you can hear their stories right here
and please don't forget to subscribe
down here thanks for watching i'll see
you next time